Goodbye, Iron Man, hello, Ironheart?
According to a new report by We Got This Covered,
Marvel Studios may have decided which hero
will assume the Iron Man mantle following
Tony Stark's death in Avengers: Endgame.
The outlet cites an unnamed source that claims
the bigwigs at Marvel and Disney are planning
to have Riri Williams, also known as Ironheart,
become the new Iron Man.
She is said to be scheduled to debut in the
MCU in either a Phase 4 or a Phase 5 film,
and will, quote, "have Tony's suit to help
her."
The ultimate plan for Ironheart, per We Got
This Covered's info, is to have the hero fight
alongside the New Avengers, led by Brie Larson's
Captain Marvel.
For those who haven't heard of Ironheart,
here's a brief run-down on the character:
she's an introverted teenager with genius-level
intellect who was accepted to M.I.T. at age
12.
Her smarts caused her to retreat into herself,
but when she reverse-engineered the Iron Man
Armor Model 41 suit to create her own version
of the armor, something sparked inside her.
She wound up stepping into the suit and committing
a few acts of rogue vigilantism before Tony
Stark noticed her and endorsed her wish to
become a superhero.
Ultimately, when Tony slips into a coma after
battling Captain Marvel, it's Riri who carries
on his legacy as Ironheart.
We Got This Covered's report notes that "several
characters" will attempt to rise as the new
Iron Man.
These contenders contenders include Don Cheadle's
War Machine, a close friend of Tony's, and
Tom Holland's Spider-Man, who saw Tony as
a father figure and trained under him to become
an Avenger during Spider-Man: Homecoming.
"That's not a hug I’m just getting the door.
We’re not there yet."
Apparently, both War Machine and Spidey soon
realize that the gig just isn't for them,
and Ironheart will go on to assume the mantle.
But really, how plausible is the notion that
Ironheart will be the new Iron Man in the
MCU?
Well, it certainly helps that this exact thing
has happened in Marvel Comics.
In August of 2016, WIRED exclusively confirmed
that Riri Williams would formally take the
Iron Man torch from Tony Stark during the
events of the new Invincible Iron Man #1.
On the other hand, although We Got This Covered
does cite a source, it's not a named source.
Anyone reading this report and choosing to
believe it or brush it off is doing so based
solely on the word of an anonymous source.
Now, this isn't to say that We Got This Covered
aren't reputable.
quite the opposite, actually, and the outlet
has hit the head on numerous nails in the
past, such as accurately reporting the Avengers:
Endgame leak that revealed the Chitauri would
be in the movie and reporting the news that
Robert Pattinson was in talks to become the
new Batman months before Variety confirmed
the scoop.
We Got This Covered really could be dishing
the truth here, but without any corroboration
on that source it's just impossible to know
for sure.
"Did you know?"
"...Yes."
Everything considered, this could be a legitimate
leak or just a bunch of hogwash.
It would be seriously cool to see a new hero
take over for Tony Stark, much like Anthony
Mackie's Falcon is all set up to become the
new Captain America in Steve Rogers' stead,
and it makes a lot of sense for Ironheart
to be that person, considering what went down
in the comics.
And yes, fans will certainly have to take
this report with a grain of salt.
But regardless of whether Riri Williams will
be appearing on the silver screen anytime
soon, you can probably rest assured that Kevin
Feige and Marvel know what they're doing and
that Tony Stark's legacy is in good hands.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.